okay Alicia hello Alicia where you from
originally
I'm originally from Owen machine no
Michigan yeah it's like right in the
center of the state of Michigan
okay I'm like from Central Michigan yeah
yes thank you I've been here at this
time nine months yeah I left my husband
of 18 years and we lived out here before
so I felt like the city was just calling
me like you know to come back I love
this city the city I don't know why but
I do
yeah yeah the bottom of the bottom yeah
yep I had both parents up until I was 11
then my dad did some stuff and he went
to prison then my mom became a single
mom and then you know life got a little
hard so uh for molesting two of my
friends yeah why was 11 he made me watch
this crazy stuff then no no he didn't
touch me or my sisters I have two older
sisters but amen and he might as well oh
yeah yeah and that was in South Carolina
and then we moved back to Michigan so
yeah I was a little rough especially
coming back when you know kids are mean
so when I came back they already knew
what was you know small-town talk you
know everybody my dad was well known in
the town so it made my life I had to
start fighting at that age to keep my
head above water so my life flipped
around from being innocent to having to
basically grow up real quick at eleven
so I got in a lot of trouble became a
delinquent basically you know
I'm the black sheep of the family as it
is so like it just came to be where you
know me and my sisters my oldest sister
had her own place because she had kids
I'm human at 10 years old so she had her
own place my other sister lived with me
and she became like kind of like my mom
because my mom was working two jobs she
has hardly ever home just to keep food
and you know house over I had so it just
I just went the other way you know I
just went to fight in and get in trouble
drugs and that's where I felt
comfortable after all this that happened
so I don't regret anything that's
happened because it's made me who I am
today but you know I wish I could take
some back yeah I have five I have an 18
a 17 of 14 13 and 10 my oldest three
live with my mom and my youngest to live
with their dad my husband that I just
loved
and so you're out here living street are
you I'm in a tent yeah
somebody stole all of my identification
when I first got here so and I'm from
out of state so it's like really hard to
get at my identification yeah yeah I
don't know I think I've been through
like 30 tents since I've been here
replaced clothing numerous times it's
just as crazy out here they'll take
anything that they think is valuable
insolence drug I didn't dabble with
cocaine cocaine yeah and we that smoked
weed on and off for about 18 years
almost yeah yeah I stopped when I was
having kids and then you know things
just just didn't go as planned
no oh yeah I've been clean for a length
of time like you know I've been ten
months here nine months there a couple
years here you know other than that it's
always I've always go back to it even
though I can maintain a life it's not
that I can't maintain my life it's just
you know I'm a functioning addict that's
what they call it you know I know I have
a problem I know I do it's just right
now I don't care to deal with it to be
quite honest I just I was I mean I was
with my husband from 18 to 36 so my
birthday's in a couple weeks too so I
didn't really have my life you know what
I mean it was Mike I was a mom and a
wife from the age 18 I didn't get to
have this you know so I'm like taking me
now so that's what I'm trying to do is
just do me find out why
um I haven't talked to him in a couple
months but you know me and my husband
are still good friends you know we're
not we're not gonna go we're not on bad
terms at all so I mean my I haven't
spoken to my parents in ten years since
my youngest was born we had a lot of
fallout my mom and dad didn't like my
husband they feel like because he was
older than me that he you know took me
away from mom and influenced me into
getting drugs nobody influenced I mean
yeah granted he did it but I chose to do
it you know to me I don't blame him for
that
so but because of the drugs caused me to
you know sign rights over to my oldest
three to my mom because the things that
we were going through at the time so but
my husband's the father of all my kids
and what are you familiar hmm I do it
yeah you know it's taking care of me for
nine months I haven't had to rely on I
know I never had a pimp I always tell
him I'm my own bin I take care of myself
you know I say what I want to do when I
want to do it not nobody telling me what
to do and thank God by the grace of God
you know nobody's tried to force me to
do no pimp or anything like that around
here you know they've all they like to
respect me for you know for what I do so
I don't think what I do defines me
though
because if I could if I had my ID I'd
have a job I'd rather work than do this
but it's quick money right now
I'm hoping to have a place my kids out
here that's my goal and to have a nice
job and you know and get clean for sure
they'd be the first you know if I wasn't
down here I probably wouldn't be doing
it because there's so much other things
here to do then our small towns only
flew 10 so I've lived all across this
country though me and my husband before
we came out here in 2016 we traveled the
country with our kids you know my 13 in
my 10 year old so we've been up and down
the coast both coasts across like I said
you know south or east to west and south
to north you know we've been everywhere
so it's been an adventure
from here yeah God's got me I know he
does he's got a better life for me he
came out he met he had me come on here
for a reason and I've always wanted to
be like a drunk not so much a drug
counselor but to help people that are on
the streets and you know cuz I've been
in their predicament so I know what it
takes to get out of it does that make
sense
and hopefully I can my story can touch
somebody I've been through a lot I don't
look like it I carry myself very well
but who spent a life
no problem thank you